demain dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rd france
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 23 septembre les
profs sont ils sous payés à plusieurs
milliers d'enseignants ont manifesté en
france ont exprimé leur colère et leur
mal être dont l'exécutif éducation
nationale est pourtant particulièrement
choyés avec notamment la revalorisation
salariale historique alors la france
traite hellman ces enseignants peut-on
doubler leur salaire comme l'a promis
anne hidalgo candidate à la
présidentielle le débat est ouvert et
nos invités en discuterons dans un
instant
la sortie crise entre paris et
washington prendra du temps et demandera
des actes concrets déclarations de jean
yves le drian anthony blinken lors de
leur tête à tête à new york faisant
suite à la crise des sous marins
australiens les relations se sont en
revanche toujours pas rétabli entre
parier qu'on verra le français ne
veulent qu'on va envoyer la facture à
l'australie dans quelques semaines
à 21h la campagne présidentielle
française primaire à 2to congrès fermer
les choses sérieuses commencent les
militants du parti des républicains
doivent choisir ce week-end le mode de
désignation de leur candidat
le favori des sondages des vibreurs tron
solide proposé l'idée d'une primaire à
droite du côté du rassemblement national
marine le pen relance sa campagne en
s'offrant un bain foule cet après midi à
metz pour présenter son projet
présidentiel
la présidente du rn gêné dans les
sondages par l'hypothèse zemmour mais
toujours pressenti pour un second tour
face à emmanuel maintenant
les enseignants ont donc exprimé leur
ras-le-bol aujourd'hui partout en france
une grève et des manifestations à
l'appel de quatre syndicats de
l'éducation nationale l'intersyndicale
qui parle d'une école mise à rude
épreuve notamment depuis le début de la
pandémie on retrouve notre reporter
neige et des rased devant le ministère
de l'éducation nationale nadège vous
avez donc suivi ces mobilisations
aujourd'hui et cette première journée de
grève dans l'éducation nationale l'a
tout de même été peu suivi dans
l'ensemble en tout cas nadège
absolument stéphanie alors le taux de
grévistes à la mi journée était de 3 9 %
dans le primaire un peu plus de 6 % dans
le secondaire d'après le ministère de
l'éducation nationale 1 devant lequel je
me trouve actuellement respectivement 15
et 30 2% de grévistes selon les
syndicats jean michel blanquer ministre
réactionnaire on ne veut pas bosser pour
toi avoir là c'était l'un des slogans
scandés aujourd'hui lors de la
manifestation aujourd'hui qui a réuni à
plusieurs milliers d'enseignants au
départ de jussieu alors c'est
manifestants venus des quatre coins de
l'hexagone ils réclament un plan
d'urgence pour l'éducation trois
semaines seulement après la rentrée
scolaire il estime que les annonces
faites par jean michel blanquer à la fin
du mois d'août sont loin d'être
suffisantes jean michel blanc car avait
par exemple annoncé une augmentation de
salaire pour tous les enseignants à
partir de 2022 une augmentation qui se
situe entre 29 euros et 57 euros par
mois et nadège on est loin de la
proposition d'anne hidalgo en cas de
victoire à l'élection présidentielle
absolument la maire de paris elle
propose carrément de doubler le salaire
des enseignants alors pour beaucoup de
manifestants que l'on a pu interroger au
cours de cette manifestation aujourd'hui
il s'agit d'une fausse promesse au seul
but électoraliste je vous propose à
d'ailleurs à ce sujet d'écouter deux
représentants syndicaux
il ya un manque de professeurs partout
le manque de remplaçants la question des
fermetures de classes la question du
baccalauréat qui dont la réforme est
amplifiée avec la mise en place des
évaluations locale la question aussi de
l'obligation vaccinale pour une certaine
catégorie de personnel qui à partir du
15 septembre se sont retrouvés suspendus
par exemple les psychologues de
l'éducation nationale les infirmières un
jeune collègue qui débute débute au smic
enfin 1,2 fois le smic pour être tout à
fait honnête c'est à dire allaire qui
est quand même extrêmement extrêmement
faibles enfin qui correspond pas à son
niveau de qualification et résultat on a
une grave crise du recrutement je veux
dire c'est un choix est ce qu on veut
que nos élèves enfin avec les élèves
réussissent et puis après ça derrière
c'est comme tout l'avenir de la france
le choix il est là je suis dans
l'académie de créteil et dans l'académie
de créteil on a accueilli 3000 élèves en
plus sans aucun poste en plus donc en
fait du coup mathématiquement ça fait
augmenter nos effectifs dans les dents
les classes c'est pas le tout de vouloir
faire des choses avec nos élèves il faut
en avoir les moyens et quand on a trop
d'élèves
pas assez de moyens pour les aider en
fait c'est frustrant et nadège une
revalorisation salariale qu'il n'est pas
la seule revendication des enseignants
absolument alors ils réclament également
des créations de postes des postes
d'enseignants de cpe de psychologues ou
encore de surveillants alors il faut
savoir que depuis le début du
quinquennat macron
7490 postes ont été supprimés au sein de
l'éducation nationale
autre revendication une amélioration de
leurs conditions de travail et
l'abrogation des réformes blanc coeur
alors cette mobilisation elle intervient
alors que le budget de l'éducation
nationale pour 2022 a été présenté hier
à l'assemblée nationale prochaine grande
mobilisation pour les enseignants ce
sera le 5 octobre pour une journée
interprofessionnelle pour l'emploi et
les salaires merci nadège abderrazak
pour ces précisions alors question
l'éducation nationale s'est elle
vraiment dégradée depuis le début de la
pandémie
doit-on s'inquiéter pour l'avenir de nos
enfants les profs foncé sont
particulièrement maltraitées c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage
[Musique]
et avec nous pourrons parler ce soir à
l'intérieu comme secrétaire du syndicat
snuipp fsu dans le nord bonsoir à
l'intérieu merci d'être avec nous franz
quatreboeufs délégué départemental du
modem dans le nord est également bonsoir
à vous alors un mot tout d'abord
l'intérieur sur les mobilisations
syndicats avaient appelé 4-1 précisément
appelé à battre le pavé pour plusieurs
mots d'ordre la gravité finalement assez
peu suivie
3,95 dans le primaire 6 19 pour le
software saas et les chiffres du
ministère ils sont un peu tout de même
nettement d'ailleurs supérieure du côté
des syndicats vous vous êtes déçus ou ça
ne veut rien dire finalement pour vous
non effectivement les chiffres sont pas
à la hauteur de ce qu'on aurait pu
espérer on va être honnête on aurait
aimé davantage mobilisés après je ne
savais pas la première fois que on a pas
une mobilisation à la hauteur de ce
qu'on pourrait espérer néanmoins
on aura d'autres occasions vous avez
parlé effectivement du 5 octobre donc
dans le cadre d'une intersyndicale
profil interprofessionnelle on sera de
nouveau dans la rue le mardi 5 octobre
france quattro baffe les profs 1 qui
entre autres un évoque des petits
salaires on les a entendu des conditions
de travail dégradées voir un mal-être
chez certains à ce qu'ils ont raison
aujourd'hui de se mobiliser de faire
entendre leur voix selon vous
alors bonsoir à vous madame tout n'est
jamais rose évidemment
mais je voudrais rappeler par exemple
les propos tout à fait
fondés que tenait monsieur beaupied
beach qui est le secrétaire général du
syndicat national des personnels de
direction de l'éducation nationale et
qui disait il y a de cela quelques jours
que en allemagne où les salaires des
enseignants sont très supérieurs à ce
qu'ils sont en france il y a malgré tout
des difficultés au recrutement donc le
salaire n'est pas le seul élément qu'il
convient d'améliorer je ne conteste pas
qu'il faille d'améliorer mais il faut
quand même rappeler que les enseignants
débutants les jeunes enseignants ont
gagné à peu près 200 euros nets par mois
entre décembre 2016 et décembre 2021
donc il ya eu quand même un certain
effort et je dois dire que j'étais un
petit peu navré de ce que j'entendais
dans votre reportage quand j'entends que
jean michel blanquer est un ministre
réactionnaire je suppose enfin j'ai on a
l'impression que c'est simplement parce
que ils demandent que les élèves du
primaire sachent lire écrire et compter
qu'il devient tout à coup un ministre
actionnaires ça me fait de la peine
parce que je suis depuis plus de 30 ans
enseignant en faculté j'ai des étudiants
qui ont de grosses difficultés
d'écriture d'orthographe de grammaire et
lorsque je vois le ministre qui
s'attelle à cette tâche je pense qu'elle
est tout à fait importante et que
qu'elle n'est pas réactionnaires et de
la même manière lorsque des enseignants
disent on veut pas bosser pour toi
écoutez quand on est enseignant bosse
pas pour le ministre on bosse pour la
jeunesse on bosse pour l'avenir du pays
et je suis vous savez dans un une petite
vie je n'oserais pas le nom je me suis
renseigné tout à l'heure une petite
ville à côté de toi il ya cinq écoles
sur cinq écoles il y avait aujourd'hui
un gréviste qui était un directeur
d'école en tout et pour tout et je moi
je ne manque jamais des gens qui font
grève parce que c'est respectable c'est
une liberté démocratique mais je suis
heureux de voir que la majorité des
enseignants sont conscients des enjeux
de la gravité de la situation et de la
noblesse de leur rôle de leur profession
à l'intérieu qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce
que vous répondez parce que
effectivement france
quattre baffes et un petit peu sur la
ligne en tout cas de luminy ce blogueur
qui dit
j'apporte la précision c'est pas vous
qui l'avez dit mais effectivement le
gouvernement nous dit c'est une
revalorisation historique qui a eu lieu
cette année
d'accord pas d'accord avec ça et un thaï
e bonds à toulouse excusez-moi redon
excusez moi depuis tout à l'heure j'ai
dit avec ses deux ailes je vous remercie
plusieurs choses à répondre bon mois
pour répondre effectivement mobilisation
allez vous avez raison monsieur +80
fallait l est pas la même partout sur
l'ensemble du territoire je voudrais
prendre l'exemple de la ville de roubaix
où il ya neuf écoles dans lesquelles on
a dû mettre en place le service minimum
d'accueil ça veut dire que dans ses neuf
écoles y avait plus de 25% de grévistes
ça veut dire que il ya sans doute des
disparités il ya des endroits où est la
ville de roubaix est particulièrement
touchée et marque les marques et
socialement et donc je pense que là le
malaise enseignant il
s'exprime différemment on fait en
fonction des territoires par rapport à
la mobilisation et au par rapport aux
salaires effectivement il ya une légère
amélioration pour les enseignants en
début de carrière il faut le reconnaître
la revalorisation historique dont on
parle elle ne peut pas considérer
qu'elles soient historiques elle
concerne pour l'instant les enseignants
deuxième au septième échelon c'est là
qu'elle concerne à peine un tiers des
enseignants et on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure c'est à peu près entre 30 et 40
euros par mois c'est à dire que c'est
pas suffisant pour rattraper la
situation
du salaire des enseignants en allemagne
alors effectivement des problèmes de
recrutement et qui ne sont pas forcément
liées aux salaires je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous d'ailleurs je vais
vous dire quelque chose en fait on
s'aperçoit que nous syndicalement on a
beaucoup de mal à mobiliser les
collègues quand on parle de salaire
parce que les collègues avec qui on
travaille ce sont pas des gens qui
décident de faire carrière pour faire
fortune c'est pas un métier on est riche
on n'est à l'abri de la fortune et de
l'ain fortune quand on est enseignant
c'est à dire que effectivement à une
situation où on s'en sort pas trop mal
sauf que c'est de moins en moins évident
est la raison pour laquelle il ya une
crise de recrutement c'est dire que pour
donner un
ordre d'idée pour un poste dans ces deux
au concours de professeur des écoles on
avait il ya une dizaine d'années on
avait cinq candidats aujourd'hui a plus
que trois candidats l'année dernière
dans le département du nord il ya 10 lui
enseignant stagiaire en premier degré
qui ont démissionné durant leur année de
stage c'est à dire qu'on arrive
quasiment à 5% ces trous on le nombre de
démissions a été multipliée en dix ans a
été multiplié par quatre on arrive à
quasiment 1400 démission par là c'est
trop et ça a des conséquences
sur le terrain parce que du coup
effectivement il nous manque des
personnels et puis ça a des conséquences
qu'en fait enfin s'est traduit quelque
chose ça traduit en mal être des de nos
collègues effectivement vous avez raison
là moi ça fait 21 ans que je fais ce
métier je l'aimais je n'arrêterai pas
l'année prochaine de faire ce métier et
on aspire tous à voir progresser nos
enfants nos élèves le problème c'est
qu'on a l'impression que on n'est pas
suffisamment entendue on n'a pas
suffisamment de moyens pour leur
permettre de réussir alors on va
continuer ce débat avec quelques
chiffres 1 re gardiste ce petit
comparatif du portail stati star sur le
salaire des enseignants en europe on en
parle souvent de ce comparatif le
luxembourg garder est loin devant avec
l'allemagne sur les onze pays du
comparatif la france et est en 9e
position et si l'on compare plus en
détail le salaire d'un enseignant du
secondaire c'est moitié moins entre la
france et l'allemagne que ce soit au
début de de carrière ou après 15 ans
d'ancienneté un une réaction peut-être
parce que 4,9 sur ces écarts
considérables
alors je reprends ce que disait monsieur
pop qui vix qui vous savez réagissait en
fait à la proposition de madame hidalgo
de doubler le salaire des enseignants et
il posait cette question intéressante
qui était mais quelles sont les
contreparties et il disait lui même que
les la charge de travail n'était
peut-être pas la même dans notre pays
que dans d'autres pays alors encore une
fois moi je respecte infiniment les
enseignants je suis fils et petit fils
d'institutrice on n'entendra jamais
critiqué les enseignants et pendant le
confinement les parents d'élèves se sont
rendu compte à quel point c'était un
métier ingrat et difficile mais je crois
vraiment que et pour répondre à monsieur
une grande partie du mal être des
enseignants n'est pas une question de
revenus sécu scellier malheureusement à
la dureté les difficultés de notre
société qui se traduisent y compris dans
les écoles et là il faut arriver à faire
des écoles mais dieu sait que c'est
difficile des oasis ce qui est compliqué
quand c'est dans des quartiers qui sont
eux mêmes difficiles ou dans des villes
difficile avec une population qui
s'appauvrit c'est évident mais je crois
que vraiment le salaire on peut poser la
question franchement aux enseignants
c'est à dire et je ne suis pas
sarkozyste comme l'ont été les des
membres du modem qui n'ont jamais été
sarkozyste paix est ce que les
enseignants veulent le travailler plus
pour gagner plus voyez c'est à dire que
ce dessus et ce syndicaliste monsieur
pop qu'évite j'avais raison est-ce qu'en
allemagne il ne travaillerait pas plus
est ce qu'en france ils sont prêts à
travailler plus on n'a rien sans rien et
il faut savoir que en réalité il ya un
million deux cent mille
personnel dans l'éducation nationale et
on ne s'en rend pas compte mais chaque
somme qui individuellement est faible
pour chaque enseignant représente un
total considérable sur le plan
budgétaire et malheureusement le budget
n'est pas extensible à l'infini alors
justement dans le prolongement avant de
faire réagir à linthal eux je vous
propose d'écouter un économiste
christian saint-etienne qui était
d'ailleurs sur notre antenne mercredi ça
va rejoindre un petit peu son propos
monsieur 80 écouter les annonces que
votre journaliste devant la cour des
comptes a rappelé totalement délirante
par exemple d'hidalgo de doubler les
salaires des enseignants sans préciser
que par exemple dans les pays où les
salaires sont plus élevés
les enseignants notamment en allemagne
ou ailleurs accepte par exemple
d'enseigner deux matières alors qu'en
france un enseignant de refuse
d'enseignés plus de 2 many matière les
syndicats s'y opposent totalement les
dans les autres pays où les enseignants
sont mieux payés les ces enseignants
acceptent également de travailler
davantage donc voilà on parle de doubler
les salaires sans modification
structurelle dans tous les domaines
c'est ce qui se passe à l'intérieur ça
vous inspire quoi ces propos vous paraît
vous accepteriez d'enseigner deux
matières par exemple de travailler plus
où vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord
effectivement avec ces allégations de
l'économie s'est de surcroît trop bref
également
écoutez moi je suis je suis professeur
des écoles sur vire globalement donc
vous plusieurs matières de fait de
nature c'est donc ça me fait doucement
rire je pense qu' il mute impression ça
parle effectivement du collège et du
lycée un effectivement papa des pas des
instituteurs si vous posez la question
je vous réponds m'ont conduit en lycée
pro les enseignant en lycée pro il en
disant scène ils sont vives à laon il
s'en sert de matière
c'est pas le jeu effectivement on pourra
imaginer que ça puisse se faire comme ça
je pense que c'est pas ça pas forcément
de sens par rapport au temps de travail
ce que là effectivement dit peut-être
quinze enseignants travaillent pas
suffisamment le temps de travail moyen
d'un enseignant
dans le premier degré dans le second
degré correspond à 40 4 heures par
semaine je suis désolé mais ça fait 20
ans que je fais ce métier je vois pas
comment j'ai un regret à travailler à
dégager du temps pour travailler
davantage je donne en cherchant bien je
vois pas si on va bien faire son métier
si on veut vraiment bien préparé
correctement les élèves et leur
permettre d'acquérir les compétences
pour devenir des citoyens éclairés bah
voilà il faut y passer du temps
il ya évidemment du temps en classe mais
c'est tout le temps qui est tout le
temps qu'il ya à côté un enseignant dans
le premier degré il travaille 27 heures
par semaine sauf que ça c'est ça c'est
juste le temps le temps de présence à
l'école c'est à dire que tout le reste
c'est du temps qu'il n'ait pas mesuré
cdu c'est du travail invisible si vous
voulez mais on peut qu'on s'est
improvisé pas imaginez vous un
enseignant de de petite section moyenne
section qui arriverait le matin à 8h20
pour l'accueil des élèves sans avoir
préparé tous les ateliers qui l'a après
sa demande ça demande du temps à côté
donc il ya sap il ya autre chose sur la
difficulté du métier mais je pense que
monsieur 90 le reconnaître c'est que
passer une journée avec de six heures
avec des enfants de trois à quatre cinq
six ans c'est très fatigant c'est très
fatigant et ça je pense qu'il faut il
faut pouvoir longtemps et comme vous le
disiez pendant le conflit quand les
parents se sont rendu compte de la
difficulté du métier
effectivement d'avoir ingéré un groupe
d'enfants de 4 4 points 3 4 5 6 ans
toute la journée et donc il va falloir
leur trouver non seulement voilà
les faire progresser leur apprendre
quelque chose mais aussi faire vivre un
groupe un groupe d'enfants
ensemble apprendre à sociabiliser
apprendra à travailler ensemble et tout
ça c'est difficile donc sur l'appui
après sur le doublement des salaires la
fsu le syndicat auquel j'appartiens n'a
jamais réclamé le doublement des
salaires c'est une proposition de la
ville d'algos donc moi j'ai
effectivement on est pour une
revalorisation des salaires mais comme
je dis c'est pas forcément l'alpha et
l'oméga de notre métier tous et c'est
parce qu'on cherche à dire ce qui nous
pose problème aujourd'hui ce qui pose
problème aux enseignants c'est les
conditions de travail qui sont ici je
voudrais quelques exemples le le fait
qu' il ya eu il ya des démissions et il
ya des collègues qui demandent des
ruptures comment celles actuellement on
se retrouve à faire la rentrée dans le
département du nord il nous manque ce
qui manque c'est l'inspecteur d'académie
qui le reconnaît le 3 septembre il
manque 50 4 personnes pour occuper
l'ensemble des postes dans le
département du nord le premier degré il
manque 54 personnes le jour de la
rentrée donc ce sont des remplaçants qui
vont boucher les trous sauf que ses
remplaçants on l'a besoins au fur et à
mesure de l'année parce que les
collectes tombe malade et aujourd'hui
monsieur l'inspecteur d'académie leur
thé au cdn de la semaine dernière le 17
septembre il reconnaît qu'il y a environ
130 enseignants non remplacés
toutes les semaines dans le département
du nord donc ça c'est fatigant parce que
du coup comment elles comment ça se
passe les enfants ne peuvent pas être
répartis ils sont quand même la partie
dans des bulles donc on se retrouve avec
des classes qui sont plus chargées on se
retrouve avec avoir à gérer ses
problèmes de non remplacement et puis à
des conséquences par exemple on parle du
doublement le doublement le dédoublement
des classes en cp enseignants en
éducation prioritaire qui une des
mesures phares du gouvernement en fin du
quinquennat macro et peu et de et de
blanca si un enseignant un de ces deux
enseignants de céder les deux c'est
perdre ou si l'un des deux qui est
absent le dédoublement issa nul en fait
va demander à l'enseignant d'avoir à
gérer lançant par an peuvent le
constater pas beaucoup de remplacements
en tout cas quand on est dans l'école
publique ça c'est sûr a du primaire
jusqu'au lycée
dernière question justement sur cette
proposition d'anne hidalgo on ne
rappelle évidemment ce qu'il fallait
qu'elle est candidate à l'élection
présidentielle qui propose de doubler
ses salaires france 4,9 c'est quoi cette
une proposition démagogique ou ou
réaliste enfin où est ce qu'on peut
trouver cet argent finalement ça paraît
réaliste pour vous un enseignant me
disais tout à l'heure que ça
représentait à peu près 150 milliards
d'euros sur cinq ans oui c'est
complètement farfelu
voyez c'est ça rappelle un peu les
propositions de françois hollande quand
il annonçait une taxation des ddd grands
revenus qui a été retoquée par les eaux
du riz diction et sur lequel elle
laquelle il a dû complètement reculer
c'est à dire que et et ses cibles et moi
je suis un vieux militant un vieux
militants centristes
j'essaie toujours de ne jamais rien
promettre que je ne puisse pas tenir
parce que promettre n'importe quoi c'est
ouvrir grande la porte au populisme
parce que ça exaspère et je regrette que
madame hidalgo se livrent à ce genre de
surenchère parce qu'effectivement c'est
un faisable d'ailleurs les syndicats
ogbl n'y crois pas heureusement c'est un
faisable et c'est de nature comme
toujours à désespérer à mettre en colère
et c'est ce qui conduit aujourd'hui
hélas au désaveu des politiques à à
l'abstention massive au vote populiste
et je regrette que madame hidalgo se
fasse le fourrier du populisme je le
regrette vraiment merci en tout cas à
tous les 2 france 4 boeuf à linthal
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france pour ce face à face merci
conséquence à présent de l'annulation du
contrat du siècle autres manifestations
en france celle des salariés de naval
groupe devant le siège de l'entreprise à
paris au moins 1000 emplois seraient
menacés au sein de cette société
spécialisée dans la construction navale
de défense en raison de cette rupture du
méga contrat de sous marins français au
profit des états unis les précisions
avec david khalifa
une action prévue bien avant la rupture
de ce contrat pharaonique avec
l'australie mais qui s installe dans la
continuité des revendications de la cgt
finalement ils réclament une meilleure
répartition des richesses et surtout un
treizième mois ils demandent également
la préservation de l'emploi suite à la
rupture de ce contrat pharaonique avec
l'australie 350 emplois sont concernés
directement basé en australie et dans
l'hexagone 650 employés sont concernés
par cette rupture de contrat dont 500 à
cherbourg la première crainte de la cgt
c'est que le groupe naval utilisent
cette rupture de contrat avec
l'australie comme prétexte pour mettre
en place des plans sociaux alors que
l'entreprise a une bonne santé
financière et coûtait pas forcément une
inquiétude pour les salariés qui sont
impactés par la rupture de ce contrat
brutal on va dire
c'est pour ça aussi d'ailleurs qu'on est
là mais on est aussi là pour revendiquer
dans un premier temps de 13e mois et en
quelque part on profite de ce cet impact
négatif pour
pouvoir se battre et défendre dans un
cuir est justement ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure c'est répartir la
richesse et
et on veut aussi du réinternaliser le
travail qui part dans les chantiers à
bas coût et c'est donc ré internaliser
pour qu'on puisse servir de marine
nationale on laissera pas une direction
profiter de la situation pour réduire
les emplois on a de nombreux contrats
qui sont aujourd'hui en cours sous marin
est troisième génération snl de
troisième génération pour la france on a
les barracuda qui sont encore à terminer
on a livré le premier mandant là encore
cinq autres a livré derrière on a un
porte-avions a réalisé donc notre note
revendicatif c'est vraiment clairement
de se reconcentrer sur la stratégie
d'entreprise sur la stratégie de la
défense pour la france elle l'a rappelé
encore hier à notre pdg on ne laissera
personne
partir de l'entreprise à cause de la
cause de cette rupture de contrat le pdg
réaffirme partout que nous on nous avons
une entreprise qui est résilient qui est
forte
nous aujourd'hui une autre action elle
est plutôt sur les salaires parce que on
estime que les salariés de nava groupes
doivent pouvoir bénéficier
de la richesse produite par leur travail
que l'on soit ouvrier soudeur ou pdg on
travaille tous pour la richesse de
l'entreprise comme vous pouvez le voir
l'action s'est déroulée au sein même des
locaux de naval groupe dans le 15e
arrondissement de paris plusieurs
centaines de personnes se sont réunies
ici même issus de toute la france de
lorient de tout le rond de brest ou bien
encore de cherbourg une délégation a été
reçue à 13h par une interlocutrice de la
direction rien n'en est sorti mais
l'objectif premier des manifestants ici
était de faire pression sur la direction
notamment pour ces augmentations de
salaire et le 13 et moi mais aussi pour
la préservation de l'emploi beaucoup
d'incertitudes demeurent également sur
l'indemnisation promise par l'australie
et la suite de la rupture de ce contrat
mais également sur la perte du chiffre
d'affaires 1 même si le pdg s est montré
rassurant et a affirmé qu'il allait
transmettre une facture détaillée et
chiffrée à l'australie dans les
prochaines semaines et sur le plan
diplomatique les discussions entre paris
et washington continue après le coup de
fil hier entre joe biden et emmanuel
macron les ministres français et
américain des affaires étrangères se
sont rencontrés cet après midi à new
york en marge de l'assemblée générale
des nations unies on y retrouve tout de
suite notre correspondant thomas abonnés
bonsoir thomas qu est ce qui ressort de
cet entretien aujourd'hui entre les deux
hommes
et bien c'est une deuxième étape en deux
jours vers un retour à la normale des
relations entre paris et washington la
rencontre s'est déroulée dans les locaux
de la mission diplomatique française
auprès de l'onu aucun média et donc
aucune image de cet entretien entre les
deux ministres français et américain à
des affaires étrangères lieu de
rencontre qui a duré environ une heure
et la seule publication sur cet
entretien c'est finalement un communiqué
du ministère français des affaires
étrangères regardez
j'ai rencontré ce matin à new york mon
homologue américain anthony blinken pour
engager un processus de discussions
approfondies entre nos deux pays sortir
de la crise que nous vivons prendra du
temps et requerra des actes
alors on ne perçoit pas encore à un
retour à une entente parfaite entre les
deux chefs de la diplomatie française et
américaine qui annonce toutefois qu'ils
vont maintenir un contact étroit pendant
ces prochaines semaines on peut sentir
une certaine prudence de la part de jean
yves le drian qui on le rappelle a eu
des mots très dur toute la semaine à
l'encontre de washington il avait même
affirmé en début de semaine ici à new
york qu'il ne prévoyait pas de
rencontrer son homologue américain mais
finalement cette rencontre a bel et bien
eu lieu et cela a été rendu possible par
un premier entretien vous l'avez dit un
entretien téléphonique entre joe biden
emmanuel macron qui s'est déroulé un
mercredi alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que du côté américain on souhaite
communiquer sur un retour à la normale
un apaisement des relations entre paris
et washington preuve à l'appui avec
cette photo qui a été postée sur les
réseaux sociaux de joba y donne une
photo prise au moment où le président
américain s'entretenait par téléphone
avec emmanuel macron et envoie le
locataire de la maison blanche tout
sourire évidemment c'est une façon pour
lui de communiquer sur le fait que la
discussion elle s'est bien passé c'est
d'ailleurs aussi ce qu'a dit la porte
parole de la maison blanche en affirmant
que l'entretien avait été amicale alors
en ce qui concerne emmanuel macron il
n'y a toujours eu aucune prise de parole
publique depuis le début de cette crise
diplomatique mais le retour de
l'ambassadeur de france aux états unis
dès la semaine prochaine peut être
considérée comme un pas vers un retour à
des relations normales entre les deux
pays la question maintenant est de
savoir si ce froid diplomatique
elle va avoir des conséquences
stratégiques de la part de la france qui
a dit donc attendre des actes de la part
de washington l'occasion aussi de
mesurer à quel point la diplomatie
américaine veut véritablement renouer un
lien de confiance avec paris alors le
prochain point d'étape ce sera à la fin
du mois d'octobre puisque c'est à ce
moment là qu'une rencontre va être
organisée entre joe biden emmanuel
macron elle se déroulera en europe merci
thomas abonnés en direct de new york et
on continue d'en parler avec vous régis
le sommier grand reporter rt france
bonsoir régissait laurière le bonheur et
la réconciliation avait l'air simple
comme un coup de fil mais aujourd'hui
quand même jean yves le drian précise
qu'il faudrait quand même montré des
preuves d'amour à des actes pour sortir
de cette crise déjà à quel acte concret
on pourrait penser peut-on s'attendre de
washington
à écouter le problème c'est tout le
problème est là aujourd'hui il ya eu un
affront il ya un contrat de 50 milliards
de dollars qui a échappé à la france
alors il y aura évidemment des
compensations financières parce que on
n'engage pas ce contrat d'ailleurs a été
signée il ya plusieurs années il a
engagé un certain nombre d'ouvriers je
pense en particulier à ceux de la région
de cherbourg moi j'en connais
personnellement qui travaille pour la
base navale groupe et qui aujourd'hui
s'interrogent sur l'avenir de leur
emploi également en australie parce que
ça ce contrat comment ne recoupent et
quelques quarante mille personnes en
australie lui et 60% des sous marins
étaient prévus les peut-être construit
sur le continent australien donc c'est
beaucoup on était allé très loin on
avait engagé beaucoup de choses je
rappelle qu'au moment où toni morrison
le premier ministre australien décide de
annonce la rupture de ce contrat est
bien les australiens avaient envoyé un
courrier à la france leur expliquant
toute leur satisfaction
sur l'avancée du projet des sous-marins
français donc contradiction totale et là
puisque ce sont les américains qui en
décider et on comprend très bien on le
voit très bien que c'est une décision
stratégique des américains de reprendre
la main dans cette zone pour faire face
à la chine en imposant leur technologie
une technologie d'ailleurs qui on le
rappelle n'arrivera pas avant 2040 alors
que celle de la france était prévu pour
2030 donc quand on connaît l'état
d'avancer l'âge de la flotte chinoise et
l'évolution rapide de l'armement chez
les chinois qu'on est sensé contrecarrer
dans cette zone ça fait que très tard
donc il y à une interrogation qui
demeure c'est pourquoi tout ça s'est
arrêté pourquoi les américains et
pourquoi les australiens ont décidé
justement de faire bande à part et de
d'humilier les français et la question
aujourd'hui de deux rames de renvoyer de
rappeler les ambassadeurs de les
renvoyer de faire des coups de fil de
fer des entretiens bilatéraux comme il
ya eu lieu aujourd'hui entre le
secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken et le ministre des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian tout ça
c'est de la diplomatie je dirais que
c'est une une façade c'est pour montrer
qu'on ne perd pas la face maintenant la
question de la nature des actes qui
pourraient compenser cette perte de
contrats et bien elle reste inconnue on
ne sait pas si les américains
autoriseront les français puisque la
question et tout est là aussi puisque on
est on est dans cette alliance la france
réparti de l'otan la france est liée aux
etats-unis elle a décidé de lier sa
diplomatie
osez à celle des états unis en
réintégrant sous nicolas sarkozy le
commandement intégré de l'otan eh bien
ça nous bloque certaine façon est comme
gelée déjà dit sur cette antenne le
problème de la france c'est qu'elle
devrait aujourd'hui au nom c'est à
regarder à nous et outre alliance il y à
des acteurs dans la région il ya des
acteurs dans le monde je parle de danse
en particulier aux turcs aux iraniens et
même aux russes puisque c'était une des
intentions premières d'emmanuel macron
de deux façons de finalement à ne pas
être à la remorque des états unis
puisque on se rend compte que en dépit
de cette crise et puis des commandes et
des salamalecs parce que c'est de ça
qu'il faut par les combats auxquels on a
assisté ces jours derniers eh bien la
france est considérée comme un
partenaire secondaire un partenaire sur
lesquels on peut
s'essuyer les pieds véritablement et je
pense que ça a provoqué la colère des
manuels macro une colère vraiment
profonde maintenant quelle va être la
réponse stratégique de la france les
états unis ont décidé de montrer qu'ils
avaient une stratégie différente dans
cette zone en australie et en inde et
nous quelle va être la nôtre pour les
années à venir je pense qu'on est
actuellement un moment pivot sur la
commande le la politique étrangère de la
france en général j'ai justement vous
l'avez évoqué vous avez déjà enquêté sur
ma deuxième question effectivement
l'opposition aux françaises elle s'agace
un de jean-luc mélenchon à marine le pen
de 2,7 entre guillemets molette
française pour pour résumer un petit peu
tous les tweets
mnr macro aurait dû être inspiré d'être
un peu plus ferme justement parce que
c'est sûr que ces rappels d'ambassadeur
les retrouvailles fin octobre ça fait
pas forcément bonne impression à tout le
monde en france
bah écoutez ça c'est un cetain le
minimum que mike emmanuel macron pouvait
faire il ya chaque fois qu'on rappelle
son ambassadeur ça veut dire qu'il ya
crise les propos de jean yves le drian
aussi ne cachez pas justement le fait
qu'il y avait une rupture de quelque
chose maintenant une semaine plus tard
on se rend compte que un coup de fil
suffit à commander un petit peu à calmer
les esprits que on
dialogue mais que dans les fêtes de la
part de la france aucune mesure décisive
noël n'a été prise alors la question
aussi c'est la pl peut-être la place de
la france dans l'otan un souvenons nous
des années de la fin des années 70 le
général de gaulle a décidé
unilatéralement de retirer la france du
commandement intégré de l'otan à
l'époque ça avait provoqué effectivement
à taulé le général de gaulle avait
d'ailleurs une politique qui était bien
plus comment une politique de se plaçant
entre la russie et les etats unis à
l'époque on était en pleine guerre
froide et il avait eu son courage de
retirer la france de cette alliance qui
semblait
ne pas convenir à cette position à la
position stratégique qui a la politique
étrangère de la france aujourd'hui le
problème c'est ce suivisme dont on a
fait preuve depuis je rappelle encore
davantage depuis le retour de la france
dans le commandement intégré si nicolas
sarkozy on a été suiviste des états unis
et on a ça nous a peut-être empêché
d'avoir une vision stratégique une
vision mondiale propre même si elle doit
s'inscrire dans un jeu d'alliances et
qu'il n'est pas nécessaire de rompre
avec nos alliés traditionnels mais il y
a il faut faire entendre notre voix et
notre voix ne se fait pas assez entendre
sur beaucoup de conflits on a été
absents sur beaucoup de deux zones le
monde est en train de changer on le voit
le retrait des américains d'afghanistan
bouleverse la donne c'est ce retour des
américains dans la zone australienne
face à la chine bouleverse la donne et
il est important que la france se
repositionne jeu plage irait aussi
peut-être 7 c et est rapidement s'il
vous plaît parce qu'on arrive au bout
est ce qu'elle en a les moyens la france
2 de se repositionner et de pesée de
compter écoutez depuis que la france est
présente en afrique avec l'opération
comment d'abord serval puis barkan la
france a montré qu'elle était capable de
se projeter en opérationnel à l'étranger
qu'elle est capable de 2 comment de tuer
des leader djihadiste elle l'a fait
encore la semaine dernière avec abou
walid al sahraouis qui était le patron
de leuilly gs de l'état islamique dans
le grand sahara elle a cette capacité de
projection également souvenez vous de
l'opération hamilton sur la syrie où la
france a mené seule cette opération
depuis ses bases aériennes françaises
jusqu'à la syrie donc quand elle veut se
déployer la france est capable de le
faire elle a une flotte sous-marine
conséquente c'est une puissance
considérable il faut qu'elle fasse notre
de cette puissance et il faut aussi
qu'elle regarde dans les zones dans
lesquelles elle opère peut-être moi je
pense particulièrement à la turquie il
ya eu un presque un affrontement entre
la france et la turquie autour autour de
la grèce et au tour justement des
gisements d'hydrocarbures qui sont
larges de cette zone que la tuque qui
convoitent las ça s'est porté au secours
de la grèce elle a d'une certaine façon
jouer le rôle que l'europe ne joue pas
et mais il est important peut-être aussi
pour la france d'entamer un dialogue et
d'essayer de voir des alliances
stratégiques justement avec un certain
nombre de pays et on n'est pas obligé
d'en référer constamment aux états unis
parce que on voit que eux quand ils font
leur accord quand ils vont voir les
australiens quand ils vont voir les
anglais et bien il nous en parle pas et
à la fin ça nous coûte 50 milliards de
dollars c'est cher effectivement
l'addition merci à vous régis le sommier
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre analyse
et nous n'allons une annulation du
contrat du siècle par canberra au profit
des états unis au détriment de paris
donc une industrie française de
l'armement pointé du doigt par deux ong
ainsi que le média disclose il demande à
paris plus de transparence sur ses
exportations d'armes les arbres qui
pourrait potentiellement terminé entre
les mains de la coalition militaire qui
soutient le gouvernement du yémen dans
une guerre au lourd bilan humain les
détails avec yamina benguigui da par son
silence et son manque de transparence
sur les exportations d'armes la france
aurait violé la loi le refus de
communiquer ces informations douanières
constitue une atteinte disproportionnée
au droit fondamental du public de
recevoir les informations nécessaires à
l'exercice d'un débat public légitime et
démocratique
la requête se fonde sur le droit d'accès
aux documents administratifs inscrit
dans la loi amnesty international le
centre européen pour les droits
constitutionnels et humain et le média
disclose demande à l'administration
douanière française de communiquer sur
les quantités les dates et les
destinations finales du matériel de
guerre exportés vers l'arabie saoudite
et les émirats arabes unis des
informations qui ne peuvent pas et ne
doivent pas rester ceci danse selon les
ong et les médias disclose et s'ils
tiennent tant à leur requête c'est parce
qu'ils dénoncent un risque considérable
que des armes françaises soit utilisées
contre des populations civiles au yémen
la france se défend et assure que les
armes vendues sont destinés à la défense
saoudienne des systèmes de défense
aérienne basée sur des radars et un
système de contrôle en de commandes de
thales qui ont vocation à protéger les
populations saoudienne des attaques de
drones deuxième exemple les robots
dédiés au déminage
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats arabes
unis forment une coalition engagées dans
le conflit yéménite les deux pays
soutiennent militairement le
gouvernement sunnite opposée aux
rebelles houthi sheets et de riches
nations du golfe sont des clients
importants et fidèle de l'industrie
d'armement françaises et ils les
utilisent ses produits dans ce conflit
cette année l'arabie saoudite est même
devenue le premier client de la france
le yémen le pays le plus pauvre de la
péninsule arabique est déchirée depuis
2014 par une guerre qui a fait des
centaines de milliers de morts et poussé
plus d'un million de personnels exil
intérieur et plonger des millions
d'habitants dans la famine
dans l'actualité également la démission
de l'émissaire américain en haïti daniel
foot dénonce les expulsions inhumaine
par les etats-unis de milliers de
migrants rake est un haïtien une
expulsion qui s'est intensifiée ces deux
derniers jours pour autant cette menace
ne décourage pas bon nombre de migrants
qui continuent de fuir ce petit pays des
caraïbes
série es b
scènes de colère en haïti
des dizaines de migrants haïtiens
expulsés des états unis ont atterri ce
jeudi dans leur pays d'origine
entassés sur le tarmac de l'aéroport de
port au prince certains expriment leur
rage et tente de remonter dans l'avion
d'autres partagent leurs angoisses
[Musique]
ils ont déporté cet avion ici hansen
fait mal dans un pays où il n'ya pas de
travail ils m'ont envoyé à l'armée nous
avons nos familles nos enfants dans le
pays et les dirigeants haïtiens accepte
de signer notre expulsion
[Musique]
vols à l'aéroport où nous atterrissons
nous ne trouvons aucun accueil nous
étions là très tard hier nous n'avons
pas de président dans le pays nous
sommes dans la misère je me demande
pourquoi ils ont accepté de signer cette
expulsion
j'ai voyagé dans 12 pays et dépensé
environ 15 mille dollars c'est 100
dollars je vais démange et moi même vous
êtes trop vicieux j'ai signé depuis hier
jusqu'à présent ils ne m'ont pas donné
mon argent 100 dollars maigre
compensation pour ces familles déportées
vers un pays en proie à l'insécurité et
à l'instabilité politique
dans une lettre adressée au secrétaire
d'état anthony blinken daniel foot
émissaire américain en haïti annonce sa
démission ce jeudi il pointe du doigt
les états unis et dénonce des expulsions
inhumaine je ne m'associerai pas à la
décision inhumaine et contreproductif
des états unis d'expulser des milliers
de réfugiés haïtiens et d'immigrants
illégaux en haïti un pays où nos
fonctionnaires sont confinés dans des
complexes sécurisé en raison du danger
que représentent les gangs armés
contrôlant la vie quotidienne une
politique américaine d'expulsion de
masse qui ne décourage pas pour autant
les haïtiens malgré des conditions
sanitaires déplorables
ils sont toujours des centaines à
traverser le rio grande et dans l'espoir
désespérée de rejoindre les états unis
et dans l'actualité politique en europe
l'allemagne qui s'apprête à tourner la
page en gala merkel on est maintenant à
trois jours des élections fédérales le
gouvernement allemand pourrait changer
de visage alors que les meetings se
multiplient daver tendance lcd ou de
l'actuelle chancelière essaie toujours
de combler son retard avec les
sociaux-démocrates walid bennani
éviter la douche froide pour le parti
conservateur d'angela merkel la
chancelière allemande venue apporter son
soutien mardi à son possible successeur
sur fond de patriotisme
[Musique]
en tant que chancelière allemande armin
laschet tu poursuivre et le cap
d'attirer de nouveaux emplois ici est de
rendre l'emploi possible
vous pouvez être fiers de cette députée
de cette chancelière nous ferons tout
pour continuer son travail dans les
prochaines années et nous vous demandons
votre confiance pour l'élection à venir
une confiance ébranlée à l'image des
sifflet de plusieurs opposants venus
perturber les discours du camp des
dirigeants de la cédéao stop aux
systèmes merkel au confinement
pouvait-on lire sur l'une des pancartes
rester au pouvoir près de 16 ans le
parti conservateur critiqué pour sa
gestion de la crise sanitaire ne fait
plus soulever les foules et selon les
derniers sondages la cdu ou arriverait
en deuxième position derrière les
sociaux démocrates du spd tournant
majeur dans ces élections le 17 juillet
armin laschet tu es surpris hilare
pendant un discours du président
allemands venus rendre hommage aux
victimes d'inondations
et nos veines pour le leader du parti
social démocrate presque ému de se
glisser dans la peau d'un favori
olaf scholz 63 ans 40 ans de vie
politique député ministre est
actuellement vice chancelier
j'ai fait beaucoup de campagnes
électorales et je dois dire qu'il est
très émouvant de voir combien de
personnes me font confiance pour être le
chef du prochain gouvernement de la
république fédérale d'allemagne
une rupture souhaitée également par les
verts troisième parti dominant dans les
sondages sans leader anna lena barbeuk
seule femme en lice a déjà évoqué l'idée
au cours d'un débat télévisé d'une
alliance qui pourrait changer la donne
nous avons beaucoup de points communs
avec le spd dans de nombreux domaines de
la politique sociale nous avons surtout
besoin de verres fort pour prendre un
vrai nouveau départ un nouveau départ et
une nouvelle coalition en ligne mir en
cas de victoire les sociaux-démocrates
pourraient également se tourner vers les
libéraux ces derniers avec 10%
d'intentions de vote se sont montrés
pourtant réticent à l'idée de s'allier
avec des parties aux idées contraires
des leurs l'ère post angela merkel
s'annonce ainsi des plus mouvementées
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois pour les matiz journaliste
spécialiste de l'europe vont soir
françois paul et mathis merci d'être
avec nous on vient de le voir la charte
qui consolide son statut de favori à la
succession de daniel américaine mais on
connaît le système électoral un petit
peu compliqué en allemagne on veut dire
aujourd'hui que rien n'est fait
oui ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
dimanche ce sont des députés qui sont
élus députés au bundestag donc on élit
des partis on élit un ordre dans les
parties seront élus on n'élit pas un
chant se livrent une chancelière seule
une coalition possible entre cette
partie va pouvoir générer la désignation
d'une chancelière pour pas oublier par
exemple que la chancelière angela merkel
a mis plus de moi que trois mois quatre
mois avant d'être désigné comme futur
chef de gouvernement donc ce qui va être
connus dimanche soir sait quel est le
parti qui arrivera en tête probablement
ce sera le spd est derrière la cd ou est
encore derrière les verts mais il faudra
que les leaders de ces partis se
désignent pour une possible coalition
soit le leader du spd qui devrait
arriver normalement en tête va réussir à
former une coalition
probablement avec les verts on viens de
l'entendre et peut-être aussi avec
d'autres partis soit ils n'y arrivent
pas ce qui veut dire que même à me
l'achète même étant minoritaire même en
arrivant en seconde position pourrait
éventuellement composer une coalition si
d'autres parties acceptée le gouverner
avec lui donc c'est très compliqué mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est
particulièrement difficile en allemagne
c'est avant vous serez il y avait le
parti démocrate ou les céder ou c'est à
dire les conservateurs qui s'allier ou
ne saviez pas avec lui c'est comme ça
que les majorités se faisait ce qui est
différent cette année c'est que deux
parties de chien avait dit que
probablement il faudra trois parties
d'où les verts joueront un rôle
absolument déterminant trois partis pour
former une coalition c'est là tout
l'enjeu de ce scrutin ce qui veut dire
que vraisemblable en dealant gens ne
connaîtra pas le nom du futur chancelier
de la chute de lance au lierre
reconnaîtra simplement l'ordre d'arrivée
dans l'élection des différents partis et
un autre enjeu france info les mathis c
est celui de la participation parce qu'à
ce jour il semblerait que les allemands
ne seront pas tous complètement
passionné par ces élections il ya encore
un un taux de mobilisation est un ton
une décision assez élevé selon les
sondages en tout cas
faut tout reprendre en fait que ces
trois parties et surtout les trois lieux
riches il faut comprendre que les
allemands se trouvent face à des choix
de personnes c'est quelque chose de
nouveau avant traditionnellement les
réellement voté pour des partis mais là
les personnes et personnalités ont pris
une importance particulière dans cette
élection ce qui veut dire que ces trois
personnalités elles se ressemblent
quelque part elles sont européennes
toutes trois elles remettent pas en
cause les fondements de la politique
étrangère allemande sur les goûts sujet
elles sont d'accord et puis sur les
autres sujets
l'immigration on en a quasiment pas
parlé pendant ces élections alors c'est
très difficile effectivement pour les
citoyens allemands de se repérer dans ce
manque de différence puis lorsqu'ils se
sont affrontés ces candidats se sont dit
je ne pourrais pas gouverner seul donc
il faudra que je trouve une à
correspondant pour trouver une majorité
ce qui veut dire que la campagne n'a pas
été aussi opposés aussi pas agressive
mais aussi
dynamique que pourrait être par exemple
une campagne en france où on sent que
les candidats à la figure présidentielle
sont beaucoup plus opposés sur beaucoup
de sujets en allemagne non en allemagne
on a essentiellement parlé de deux
sujets dans cette campagne d'une part le
climat les menaces climatiques et
d'autre part relance de l'économie et
donc tous les autres sujets à son passé
un petit peu la frappe ce qui explique
en partie le fait que les citoyens
allemands dont on j'ai été mobilisé
qu'avant sur l'élection ça veut dire à
vous écouter parce que nous aussi à nous
autres français nous sommes à sept mois
d'une élection présidentielle
qu à vous écouter les enjeux ne sont pas
du tout les mêmes semble-t-il pourtant
on est très voisin c'est vrai qu'en
france on parle de climat cern de
relance économique certes lanceur
beaucoup aussi de sécurité l'immigration
tout cas les médias nous en nous en
parle beaucoup
ben c'est exact en fait en allemagne les
partis extrêmes c'est-à-dire die linke
la gauche à l'extrême gauche ou l'afd
qui est à l'extrême droite sont
suffisamment faibles pour ne pas
finalement modifié considérablement la
campagne et donc il n'y a pas de
véritable opposition je rappelle encore
une fois qu'en allemagne pour gouverner
on ne peut gouverner en coalition
et cette coalition finalement a interdit
de manière à bas un peu plus musclée sur
des enjeux de société par exemple donc
c'est vrai que sur ce plan là la
campagne en allemagne diffèrent
considérablement de ce que l'on peut
attendre l'année prochaine pour la
campagne présidentielle en france ce qui
est vraisemblable c'est que il mentait
pas la chose qui est le leader du spd va
probablement arriver en tête après la
déception qui a connu armin laschet tu
as la tête du ch et des houes et ses
multiples faux ses multiples gaffes si
on peut dire fait qu'il a été
profondément affaibli comme maddalena
berlocq dont on attendait beaucoup qui
était la verte la candidate verte mais
qui suite à des accusations de plagiat
mais je suis peut-être elle aussi à des
gaffes ne s'est pas montrée comme une
candidate chancelière à la hauteur et
donc aujourd'hui paradoxalement c'est le
ministre actuel des finances de angela
merkel qui se trouve dans la position
d'être le favori notamment parce que
c'est celui aussi qui a débloqué la
situation dans la crise sur le dégoût
c'est lui qui avait finalement permis à
l'allemagne d'accorder son accord pour
un emprunt européen ce qui était tout à
fait de nouveau allemagne et donc c'est
quelque chose qui va falloir prendre en
compte vraisemblablement ces eaux-là
schulz qui devra essayer de former sa
coalition
encore une fois rien n'est dit et le
soin et dimanche soir il n'est pas
impossible que nous n'ayons pas
d'informations suffisamment tangible
pour désigner et chancelier ou une
chancelière avec dans ce cas la chance
ou le risque c'est selon que un gala
merkel reste encore un petit peu au
pouvoir quelques mois n'est ce pas
c'était de là c'est exact la
constitution allemande fait en sorte que
à nouveau chancelier mais désigné que
lorsqu'il peut apporter la preuve qu'il
dispose d'une coalition de gouvernement
et tant que cette preuve n'est pas
apportée c'est l'actuel chancelier ou
chancelière en cas d'espèce c'est angela
merkel qui devra continuer à gouverner
il est tout à fait possible que angela
merkel soit encore chancelière
d'allemagne dans la période de noël par
exemple pas lui dire adieu trop vite
alors merci beaucoup françois houle et
mathis d'avoir été avec nous nous avons
remporté votre analyse reste avec nous
donc quelques instants on va encore
parler politique mais cette fois ci on
fera en sorte puisque on évoquera la
campagne présidentielle française qui
s'approche ce week-end les adhérents du
parti des républicains doivent trancher
entre primaire à deux tours et congrès
fermé et sondages donnent s'est dit
bertrand au grand favori pour être le
candidat ait l'air en 2022 du côté est
reine marine le pen
lance vraiment sa campagne est
aujourd'hui en s'offrant un bain de
foule cet après midi à metz elle a
présenté son projet présidentiel
un petit peu gêné par l'hypothèse
zemmour dans les sondages
[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres et le silence qui parle
[Musique]
les cheveux ras
la cij minecraft un rôle de stoppeur
[Musique]
le
joue
ce que bon
rien
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
il ya bien
que non
les puits
ça
[Musique]
engagé
et
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï ce gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la public
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il ya quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
émission consacré cette semaine aux
cryptes aux monnaies sont elles l'avenir
de l'économie
oui les crypto monnaie remplace la
monnaie fiduciaire elle remplace même
lors la province du bitcoin c'est
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
beaucoup de façons à la fin des femmes
les monnaies qu'on connaît actuellement
vaudront 0 aujourd'hui on voit très bien
que les banques centrales cherchent à
faire leur propre et aux monnaies parce
que elles veulent garder la main dessus
et ça les intéresse pas du tout d'avoir
un concurrent qui est un concurrent
libre pécan et laisse le bitcoin ne fait
pas partie de ce système personne ne le
contrôle
ça ne va pas seulement changer les
banques centrales ça va changer le
concept même de l'état nation
le bitcoin c'est une monétisation de
l'amour et de la paix des braves
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
infarctus chez les hommes que chez les
femmes ce qui nous alertent nous c'est
la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est exact à ben ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qui était accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
de son diagnostic et le traitement et
non pas sur la prévention et on aimerait
un système très curatif 1 c'est
essentiel d'avoir l'information pour pas
subir
[Musique]
neyret
il est 21h merci de vos rejoint avant
direct sur ft france pour cette deuxième
partie d'émission
primaire de tous mon gré fermer les
militants du parti des républicains
doivent choisir ce week-end le mode de
désignation de leur candidat pour la
présidentielle le favori des sondages à
vie mme bertrand se dit opposé l'idée
d'une primaire à droite il persiste du
côté du rassemblement national marine le
pen elle relance sa campagne en
s'offrant un bain de foule cet
après-midi m s pour présenter son projet
présidentiel
les présidents du rmg l'est et dans les
sondages par l'hypothèse eric zemmour
mais toujours pressenti pour un second
tour face à emmanuel macron
une primaire à deux tours ou un congrés
fermer les militants les républicains
sont donc appelés à un vote numérique
après demain on clair ses adhérents à
l'air doivent choisir la méthode de
désignation de leur futur candidat pour
la présidentielle de 2000 22 un
processus auquel pourraient participer
xavier bertrand en fonction de la
méthode choisie est détaillé avec robin
pu l
c'est aux militants républicains de
trancher ce samedi lors d'un congrès
numérique ouvert aux 82 mille adhérents
ils choisiront le mode de désignation du
candidat pour l'élection présidentielle
de 2000 22 deux solutions s'offrent à
eux soit une primaire à deux tours au
cours de laquelle pourront voter
l'ensemble des sympathisants des valeurs
de la droite et du centre l'autre option
un congrès réservée aux seuls adhérents
du parti inscrits jusqu'à quinze jours
avant le scrutin dans une vaste enquête
d'opinion menée auprès de 15 mille
sympathisants élèves c'est l'idée d'un
congrès qui semblent plébisciter ce qui
correspond de toute façon un choix de
notre électorat de droite qui aiment
l'ordre et qui ne veut pas de divisions
parce que
division nous ont amenés depuis dix ans
être dans l'opposition et on l'a bien vu
au moment des régionales il ya une envie
de gagner dans notre électorat qui est
très forte ce sondage commandé par les
républicains place également xavier
bertrand comme le candidat le plus
populaire auprès des personnes
interrogées le président de la région
ile de france a fait savoir qu'il était
prêt à se soumettre au processus de
sélection si l'option dont congrès
réservé aux militants et l'air été
choisi mais ils restent fermement
opposés à l'idée d'une primaire à droite
c'est une machine à diviser on a besoin
de se rassembler je suis un homme de
droite et je voudrais avoir le soutien
de toute la droite mais aussi porter une
candidature plus large de rassemblement
samedi prochain les adhérents se
détermineront mais je ne participerai
pas une primaire sous quelque forme que
ce soit
adversaire principal de xavier bertrand
dont la course à l'investiture
valérie pécresse ressort affaibli de
cette réunion des cadres de la droite la
proposition qu'elle défende et d'ouvrir
le vote au cours du congrès aux
militants des formations amis de la
droite et du centre a été écartée par le
bureau politique
et une éventuelle primaire de la droite
à laquelle eric zemmour se verrait
peut-être trop bien participer alors que
l'essayiste ' n'est toujours pas
officiellement candidat ses équipes
seraient en train d'étudier la
possibilité de participer à cette
primaire de la droite et du centre selon
une étude au doxa pour loeb s'il réunit
désormais 10% d'intentions de vote une
dynamique dont pâtit marine le pen qui a
relancé aujourd'hui sa campagne sur le
terrain à orange à metz en moselle
alors la primaire de la droite deux
options qui émerge de la grande enquête
lancée par les républicains auprès de
son électorat pour savoir comment
désigner son candidat à la
présidentielle et les sympathisants sont
plutôt partisan d'un congrès au lieu
d'une grande primaire ouverte d'autant
qu'eric zemmour serait donc tenté de s'y
inviter comme on vient de le dire alors
la droite se fait-elle et morizet at
elle les moyens de remporter cette
élection présidentielle c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler stéphane rozès
politologue président de cap vous êtes
également enseignant à hec et
sciences-po bonsoir stéphane rozès merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés jean
frédéric poisson vous êtes le président
du parti via la voix du peuple un
candidat à la primaire de la droite en
2017 un processus donc que vous
connaissez très bien bonsoir à vous jean
frédéric poisson donc qu'à sept ans
alors un petit peu de vérité ce week-end
chez les républicains deux options le
congrès et les primaires ouvertes que
refuse à tout prix à xavier bertrand un
congrès clairement stéphane rozès lui
serait plus favorable à xavier bertrand
qui on le rappeler est un petit bol
favori en tout cas des des sondages en
ce jour un oui xavier bertrand est
légèrement favori effectivement c'est
lui il serait favorable dans la mesure
où dès le départ dans une posture un peu
gaullienne selon laquelle une
présidentielle c'est la rencontre
directe entre le candidat et le peuple
l'avait écarté l'idée d'une primaire
néanmoins il a besoin du soutien du
parti république et donc du coup ils
auraient au travers de cette option au
fond mais ça voudrait dire ralliement du
parti républicain à sa candidature il
aurait le beurre et l'argent du beurre
alors on va voir ce que vont décider
les militants les choses sont un peu
ouverte et puis il ya eric zemmour qui
arrivait qu'il fait un peu turbulent le
système bien enfin le système
effectivement de désignation et la
droite
parler de cette hypothèse zemmour vous
êtes-vous jean-françois passant
jean-frédéric pardon comme poisson le
l'ancien candidat à la primaire de 2017
vous regrettez vous reviendriez
l'absence de primaires ouvertes cette
fois ci le parti est trop frileux selon
vous
franchement ce n'est plus tout à fait
problème si j'ose dire
mais je crois que il y a quelque chose
de faux c'est dans l'analyse que
j'entends chez ceux des républicains qui
s'opposent à la primaire il semble faire
reposer ce qu'ils considèrent comme un
échec de la primaire de 2016 la faute
sur la forme même du scrutin et je ne
partage pas cette idée je pense que si
d'abord la primaire n'a pas échoué
puisque elle a désigné un candidat qui
étaient largement majoritaires c'était
françois fillon certes avec un projet
politique peut être un peu trop libérale
par rapport à l'état de l'opinion ce qui
lui a joué quelques tours d après
d'ailleurs la sortie était de primaires
dès novembre et décembre 2016 mais je
crois que nous sommes dans un contexte
où l'opinion publique les français ont
besoin d'être consultés ils le disent
les gilet jaune m'ont dit avec une ride
référendum d'initiative citoyenne sur
les ronds-points la gauche l'avait
considéré comme une forme de tradition
la démocratie participative qui est
portée dès 2007 par madame royal enfin
on sent bien que il ya cette volonté de
participer davantage aux décisions et
d'un autre côté on constate une forme de
traumatismes des militants républicains
chez beaucoup d'entre eux sur le fait
qu' une primaire au fond leur ferait
connaître à nouveau les chèques de 2016
moi je n'ai franchement pas d'idée sur
cette question je pense que la primaire
en tant que tel un intérêt je pense
qu'elle n'est pas dans la culture de la
droite c'est ça que je crois surtout il
ya chez dans la gauche historiquement
une capacité une habitude d'opérer des
synthèses même entre des positions qui
sont très opposées dans la nuit qui
suivit la présentation d'émotion on sait
bien que au congrès du parti socialiste
d'abus et une nuit de négociations
d'échangés que le lendemain un chef et
des signes tout le monde se remet sur le
nez le lendemain matin à partir du lundi
8 heures c'est une affaire entendue
parfois en attendant il ya un procès
politique c'est la droite c'est mal
faire ça et parce que je pense que elle
elle perd de vue cette idée simple qui
correspond je crois à l'état de la
france que et bien les fondamentaux sur
lesquels la droite est assise
idéologiquement depuis très longtemps
ses fondamentaux ont vacillé au moins
dans la tête de l'opinion il n'est pas
vrai que la france est indépendante
toujours il n'est pas vrai que la
famille demeure le socle de la vie
sociale dans son ensemble il n'est pas
vrai de dire que les institutions sont
stables et pérennes tout ça est
questionné désormais par l'opinion il
faut donc que la droite se réapproprie
l'état de l'opinion qu'elles repartent à
la conquête pédagogique de l'opinion ça
ne se fait pas sans la consulter donc je
crois que je termine en une phrase par
brou j'étais un peu long au fond le
problème n'est pas tant de savoir s'il
faut une primaire ou non le problème est
de savoir quel est le mode de
désignation qui correspond le mieux
aujourd'hui pas seulement à l'état
depuis donc unique à sa demande mais
aussi à l'étape politique du pays et ce
à quoi je crois les républicains ont du
mal à répondre alors la fameuse
hypothèse zemmour dont confère noces de
figaro nous dit que les proches de
zemmour aimerait bien le voir s'inviter
dans dans cette primaire on entend déjà
christian jacob gérard larcher dira non
non il n'a pas sa place ici clairement
stéphane rozès est ce que eric zemmour
aujourd'hui est de droite républicaine
ce qu'il aurait sa place dans une
éventuelle primaire de la droite et du
centre
et comme cern le parti républicain
s'est essayée dirigeants et militants de
répondre mais irrigue seymour au fond
dans son diagnostic
de du malheur français
aussi contre une approche souverainiste
est identique ariste de sebring foulard
il ne serait pas illégitime ou en tout
cas au sein du parti républicain
on parle moins possible de zemmour bedek
les micros sont pas là où ne parle pour
l'heure que de ça et notamment chez les
jeunes du parti républicain il un succès
certain au fait il semble sortir la
droite de ses divisions par par
l'extérieur pour tout un tas
d'électeurs alors les sondages disent
qu'il prend au rassemblement national
marine le pen ainsi 10% même si il prend
à droite et au chu dans l'idée qu'il
pourrait
régénérer et finalement
j'ai les formations de droit d'être à
l'écouté du pays à partir d'un
diagnostic
et c'est là sa vie bertrand doit faire
très attention
il ne doit pas apparaître dorénavant au
fond comeau signant en fonction de ses
rapports avec des dirigeants politiques
du parti
républicain
zemmour se réclame aussi du général de
gaulle il aurait à mon avis sans
problème
250 parrainage et la pression va être
forte pas seulement ce week end mais
après si eric zemmour devais y aller sur
la droite traditionnelle
alors jean fred avec passons aux
attaquantes d'avant pour la
présidentielle de 2000 22 aussi vous
faites un tweet un petit peu sibyllin
aujourd'hui on va le regarder avant de
vous de nous demander l'explication
on retrait de ma candidature
présidentielle 2022 il soutient celle
d'eric zemmour s'il se présente ce
serait possible si alors je m'entraîne
avec passant vous vous proposait
d'apporter votre soutien à eric zemmour
sous certaines conditions ces trois
petits points qui font la différence
alors lesquels ce soir finissez votre
tweet
deux conditions que j'ai précisé dans un
communiqué puis chez nos confrères de
sud radio est fière
première condition que le projet qu'il
présente aux français s'infléchissent de
manière très sensible dans le sens clair
de la prise en compte de la fragilité
des fragilités connaissent les français
tout le monde peut comprendre que un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes sont
très inquiets de voir la france d'éviter
se diluer avec une crainte de
disparition notre mode de vie notre
modèle social de notre culture par
endroit toute souveraineté c'est déjà
assez largement fait et ça inquiète une
bonne partie de l'opinion publique la
maîtrise des flux migratoires la lutte
contre l'immigration et le
rétablissement de notre identité sont
des choses nécessaires à faire tour
répondre à cette inquiétude mais ça ne
suffit pas car toutes ces inquiétudes ne
sont pas de nature culturelle ou
souveraine il ya des fragilités social
qu'il faut soi et je pense qu'il est
indispensable si on veut redresser le
pays et faire en sorte que des français
aille mieux puisque ça dangereux cette
dimension sociale doit être intégré dans
son projet pour l'instant on a va mal ou
peu mais il reste encore beaucoup de
réponses à apporter puis la deuxième
condition elle vient d'être esquissé par
par monsieur rozès il ya quelques
instants au fond je pense que la lecture
que fait le parti des républicains sur
l'état de la france est incomplète ce
qui me laissait dire c'est la nature des
solutions qui la porte ou que les
candidats à porte en général c'est à
dire plutôt des réponses soient plutôt
de marketing soit de gestion mais ça ne
suffit pas la france n'est pas seulement
mal géré la france ne va pas bien elle
est profondément marqué par la violence
par des fragilités et ce ne sont pas des
réponses techniques qui permettent de
régler ce genre de problème ce sont des
réponses politiques et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense que celui qui
acceptera l'idée que cette réponse
politique est capable de donner
l'impulsion à la refondation du droite
qui serait attentive à cette dimension
politique celui-là a de très fortes
chances non seulement de bien figurer à
l'élection mais également de l'emporter
donc c'est pour ça que j'appelle eric
zemmour à réfléchir profondément à
l'idée d'un rassemblement de ce qui
serait une confédération de tous les
mouvements qui sont attachés à cette
secte ur et qui sont grosso modo des
mouvements conservateurs sociaux dans
leur inspiration si ces deux conditions
sont réunies
d'abord le fait que la fragilité que
subissent bon nombre des français
d'aujourd'hui est prise en compte
réellement dans son projet politique et
deuxièmement qu'il est d'accord pour
impulser ce projet confédéral de
reconstitution d'une droite
conservatrice et social alors je ferai
le constat que quelqu'un qui porte le
même projet politique que moi est mieux
placé que moi est dans la droite ligne
de ce que je porte depuis quelques
années si quelqu'un est mieux placé que
moi et portent le même projet que moi je
n'ai pas de raison d'être candidat
contre lui je n'ai d'ailleurs pas de
raison tout court d'être candidat et
donc j'apporterai mon soutien ma pierre
à cet édifice et j'y mettrai toute mon
énergie en tout cas son nom est sur
beaucoup de lèvres comme l'a expliqué
stéphane rozès tout à l'heure marine le
pen a notamment qui a lancé sa campagne
interrogé sur justement cette hypothèse
m pour écouter la réponse là l'ex
présidente du rassemblement national
candidate à la présidentielle
j'ai vu beaucoup de candidats suscité un
intérêt médiatique
en réalité lorsque l'intérêt médiatique
s'essouffle les candidatures de ces
personnalités elle-même s'essouffle à
une candidature médiatique eric zemmour
quelle est votre opinion stéphane rozès
ça va faire puis parce que c'est vrai
que c'est sur toutes les lèvres dans
tous les médias
oui bien sûr mais de toute façon je fais
partie des rares politologue qui pensent
non pas que les médias ou la classe
politique impose ou pays quoique ce soit
mais que celle inverse que c'est le
rapport du pays au réel l'évolution de
ces perceptions à partir de son
imaginaire et de ses fondamentaux qu'il
fait assez rapidement les médias et plus
lentement le système politique prend en
compte ce qui émerge un hameau me
succède essayiste d'eric zemmour en
termes d'audience de pente de livre
rencontre un sentiment plus anciens
d'une dépression française d'un
déclassement de notre modèle le fait que
les deux tiers des français estiment
depuis cinq ans qui ne semble plus en
france comme chez eux le fait que les
deux tiers des français
l'appel des généraux dans l heure
actuelle ne les voyant pas comme ce sont
peut-être certains d'entre eux des
putschistes extrême droite mais plutôt
comme des lanceurs d'alert
montre mes estimations
d'une langue malheur
ressentie par des français très divers
de droite de gauche de conditions
sociales différentes que la chatterie
qui était déchiré jaunes soutenues par
les deux tiers des français
expriment moi j'ai toujours analyser ça
comme demande de retour de l'autorité
politique et de la souveraineté comme
une chatterie qui appartient de la
question fiscale le retour des devoirs
du souverain bien tout ce contexte fait
que eric zemmour alors qu'au départ sans
nous qui n'y pensais pas est porté par
quelque chose et djiby bâ finalement
pourquoi je n'irai pas d'autant que
puisque vous parlez de marine le pen son
analyse est à tort ou à raison je pense
que ça peut se discuter
son analyse est que au fond marine le
pen comme une leader ne peut plus porter
quoi que ce soit parce qu'au fond selon
lui dans sa façon d'être de faire
d'analysé des régionales les cantonales
elle n'aurait plus la dynamique canadair
alors là où je rejoins monsieur poisson
c'est quand il faudra qu eric zemmour
précise ses griefs c'est à dire qu'il ya
une petite citation chayrigues zemmour
entre une réponse ou vrai ni style dandy
taris bizarrement marine le pen à faire
un mouvement bouhenia ces derniers un
seul à nier et il faut faire la
démonstration pourrir exim or que silva
à la présidentielle s'est pas seulement
pour témoigner pas seulement dias il va
pas pas seulement dire pourquoi la
france chute ou tombent mais de dire
dire quelque chose de possible
hélas sa demande effectivement pour eric
zemmour mais c'est normal que tout ça
soit de son point de vue en construction
un certain nombre de précisions parce
qu'ils y compris dans ses critiques
marine le pen on ne sait pas très bien
si la critique sur ce problème de
leadership ou sur une orientation qu'il
considérait comme au fond trop social
trop républicaine trop nationale bref
tout ça promet des clarifications mais
clairement et réalisé moore arnaud
montebourg sont les deux nouveautés de
cette présidentielle parce que
explicitement encore plus que marine le
pen dorénavant une pose la question de
l'avenir de notre modèle pour l'heure
est réglée mourant donne réponse plutôt
identite' ariste arnaud montebourg
plutôt souverainiste social mais je
pense personnellement que le succès de
la présidentielle sera le retour de la
souveraineté de la nation et remettre
l'état ou service de la nation
jean-frédéric passant le mot de la fin
pour vous et effectivement eric zemmour
profitent de de cet espace qu'on lui
laisse
aller pons j'ajoute pas ce que vient de
dire stéphane rozès une enquête qui
sorti il ya quelques jours et qui disait
que près de deux tiers des français
considère que la france est en déclin ce
qui rejoint la longue liste des sondages
que nous si rose et ça lui même a
rappelé sur ce sentiment d'évitement je
crois que on peut lire effectivement si
on va un peu vite l'émergence d'eric
zemmour comme quelque chose qui ne
relève que de la qualité des audiences
qu'il rassemble sur ses news ce serait
aller un peu vite en besogne car je
partage parfaitement la vie de monsieur
rozès sa position sa fidélité à la
tradition de l'histoire française au
fond dont on peut discuter de lecture
sur certains des épisodes mais
globalement sa filiation très clair dans
la tradition de l'histoire française
rejoint quelque chose qui est attendu
par l'opinion est ce que ce rapport
d'une certaine manière il perçoit les
militants de cette fidélité parce que
personne d'autre ne l'exercent les
personne d'autre ne fait cet exercice de
référence à ce qui a fait notre passé et
glorieux ou moins glorieux
par ailleurs je mon sentiment c'est que
d'une certaine manière l'espace est
ouvert je vois bien des réactions de m
le pen aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que
parmi les causes du déclin de la france
on peut imaginer que en tout cas ceux
qui sont comme moi donc ce que rennes là
je réponds pour moi pas pour monsieur
zemmour bien sûr
pour moi des très grands critiques est
très constant critique de la
construction européenne que nous avons
sous les yeux le fait que le
rassemblement national est abandonnée
successivement ces derniers mois l'idée
de sortir de schengen
l'idée de sortir bako européenne des
droits de l'homme renoncer absolument à
toute idée de phr excite et abandonner
la volonté de réforme eu l'euro c'est un
noyau complète son électorat qui
s'emballe là pour le coup il ya une
forme d'abandon ce qui a fait de la
tradition historique du rassemblement
national qui s'est largement constitué
sur les premiers scrutins européens des
années 80 qui a fait d'ailleurs de
quelques uns des succès électoraux
spectaculaire du parti alors dirigé par
son père donc effectivement se retrouve
orphelin de la même manière que se
retrouve orphelin chez les républicains
les militants qui attendent une certaine
fermeté je fais référence à ce que
disait de ce rodez à l'instant sur
l'autorité de l'état de la même façon se
retrouve au sein du rassemblement
national ce qui était attaché à une
attitude extrêmement ferme parce que
brigitte parfois à l'égard de la
construction européenne et ses
conséquences et au milieu de ça il y à
la détresse des français que globalement
personnes la traite et pour nuancer un
peu s'il me le permet la conclusion de
stéphane rozès à l'instant je pense que
prioritairement effectivement il ya une
demande de retour à l'autorité très
clair mais ce sentiment que l'autorité
de l'état ne fait pas tout et que si on
ne redonne pas du pouvoir aux acteurs
locaux alors on ne traitera pas comme il
faut les questions qui sont liées à la
solidarité et à l'entr'aide j'ai
l'impression tout de même s'ils ont la
conviction que ce besoin d'entraidé très
très important en deux corps social
français aujourd'hui j'espère que eric
zemmour ne comprendra et j'attends sa
réponse sur ce point puisque je lui ai
posé très clairement cette question
merci beaucoup en tout cas tous les deux
stéphane rozès jean frédéric poisson
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre analyse
c'est toujours en france au chapitre
judiciaire le procès des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 qui se poursuit
aujourd'hui la cour entendait le
témoignage de dirigeants de l'institut
médico-légal de paris ont fait le point
avec notre reporter katia pique nique
devant la cour d'assises spéciale de
paris
le directeur de l'institut médico-légal
bertrand ludes est venu témoigner
aujourd'hui ce sont ces équipes qui ont
reçu les proches des victimes tombées
lors des attentats il ya eu 154
présentation de corps du 14 au 21
novembre 2015 seulement cette gestion
dans l'urgence a provoqué l'effroi la
détresse absolue chez les familles ou
proches de victimes à propos de la
confusion ambiante de ratés dans
l'identification par exemple deux morts
ont été confondus un corps a été
présenté à une famille et ce n'était pas
le bon une famille a cru que sa fille
était vivante car on n'avait pas
identifiées autre plainte certains n'ont
eu que cinq minutes pour se recueillir
et encore sans pouvoir toucher le corps
de leur ennemi
les parties civiles ont aussi déploré un
manque d'information sur les causes du
décès par exemple les balles étaient
tels létale ou juste blessantes
évidemment l'exposé du directeur de
l'institut médico légal qui a défendu
son action à heurter les parties civiles
qui ont connu l'horreur à l'époque elles
ont dénoncé un traitement expéditif un
manque de coordination d'organisations
de formation et pour la plupart sont
repartis aujourd'hui avec leurs
questions sous l'effet d'une grande
colère en tout cas à la suite de tous
ces ratés des changements ont été
accomplis des psychologues ont été
recrutés et des chambres froides
démontable ont été achetés pour procéder
différemment désormais durant les
catastrophes de masse alors aujourd'hui
également lors d'une témoignage d'un
agent de l'antiterrorisme le bilan des
attentats un bilan terrible a été
affichée stade de france une victime
alibert 13 victimes fontaine au roi cinq
victimes sharon vingt-et-une victime
bataclan 90 victimes blessées huit cent
trente cinq victimes dont 675 au
bataclan et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi rendez
vous lundi prochain pour un nouveau
numéro en attendant l'actualité continue
toute la soirée et évidemment tout le
week-end sur rt france
[Musique]
le résultat d'un toit peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
conçoit vient de l'ignorance aujourd'hui
on a une gauche prg extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
et